un drama de épocas sobre la fidelidad y
una cinta sobre el deseo de la juventud
moderna probaron su suerte en la
competencia de cannes
la directora húngara ildikó njeri
presentó ante el jurado de cannes la
historia de mi mujer una obra maestra
tanto por la forma como por el contenido
sobre la vida de pareja la fidelidad y
la confianza
[Música]
un capitán de marina decide casarse con
la primera mujer que pase por la puerta
de un restaurante la suerte recae sobre
él y si una rubia exuberante enigmática
y mundana la película sigue durante
varios años este matrimonio donde se
instala el aburrimiento y las sospechas
de infidelidad
los actores jim a ver y la francesa
léase de forman una pareja increíble en
esta película que se desarrolla en
distintas ciudades europeas el ganador
de la palma de oro en 2015 jack odiar
regreso a la competencia en cannes esta
vez con les ola ampliada un drama sobre
las vicisitudes amorosas de tres jóvenes
en la capital francesa
les da la anp ya da se desarrolla en el
barrio del mismo nombre del distrito 13
de parís sus tres protagonistas dan
rienda suelta a su libido desbordante en
esta intriga tortuosa algunos se
enamoran otros prefieren revolotear de
flor en flor y otros encuentran su rumbo
miramos
esta película se distingue por una
fotografía impecable en blanco y negro y
una banda sonora firmada de ajn uno de
los compositores franceses de música
electrónica más prodigiosos del momento